hi welcome to another episode of get
close i'm your co-host gio and um the
best host bart yeah i would agree you
definitely are the best host and our
little bear friend is back
i don't like seeing this chair empty and
i do love seeing it filled with my
little furry buddy here um so there is
no guess it's going to be an intimate
conversation between the papa and the
mama and i'm so excited because
we don't have these
we used to we used to do this and i love
them i love them too and we used to do
this at night before we would go to bed
we'd put taika to bed and then we would
spend
at least an hour talking about
everything and anything or we would have
those 4am episodes too we would when we
used to podcast during the pandemic yes
but
as of recently we just are so exhausted
taika just does not have less energy the
older he gets i'm like what the [ __ ] he
has more energy and not like his mouth
has more energy
like he will talk to me for an hour
straight
for an hour bart's just sitting there
and it gets to the point where i'm like
going uh-huh really wow dude and then
what and i keep just answering and then
i feel myself tired not realizing it's
because i've been talking for an hour
straight my lips are parched i have no
more saliva in my mouth and i look at
you
and you're just on your [ __ ] phone
and i go ty go talk to your dad i'm also
just driving
or you're not driving sometimes you're
just sitting there it doesn't matter
who's driving he's talking to you right
or he's not talking he's arguing which
is so funny he's like i'll be taika you
be you okay yeah are we going the right
way yes i could look i have the map
that's not the right way that's not the
right way what do you mean look at this
i follow the blue line dude are you
tricking me no dude why would i trick
when do i ever trick you taika why are
we going this way it's not the right way
no because there's multiple ways to get
to the same location dude what's the
same
where we're going we're gonna go to the
restaurant that we always get your udon
from you can i love udon oh
literally
you see how natural that came out
because that literally is the
conversation and i'm so tired and then
he goes to he says i love udon and then
it goes i'm like good we're gonna go get
some right now and then it's an argument
about something there yeah it just goes
from argument to argument to arguments
can i watch your phone over there and
i'm like oh god talk to your dad taika
so then you can imagine by the end of
the night when we're in bed bed is my
favorite place to be right now it's his
favorite place to be too
but then no but then he goes to bed and
then now it's my i feel like that's
finally my hour yeah your time to just
decompress yeah and then you you and
then you tell me you're like ah i want
to get on top of you and not like in a
sexual way but just like to hug and
snuggle and i'm like that's the last
thing romantic guy can't help it you
know no i don't want you on top of me i
want a cuddle yeah i'm already caresses
but not like a [ __ ] i just picture a
log just like collapsing and landing on
top of my body it looks so sweet to me
yeah no not to me i feel like get the
[ __ ] off me i can't breathe i need my me
time do i still
are you still attracted to me no the way
no not at all you used to be nope from
the beginning uh so our love my level of
attraction has um
has changed over the years really yeah
so in the beginning i couldn't i just
didn't find you attractive
um we were friends
we were friends and you just weren't
anything that i what is this like 2004
when did we get together seven 2008
eight at the end of
at the end of eight right december yeah
um whenever i was with the other guy um
you were in the picture already because
we were all the homies
um but yeah no you're just never anyone
i was attracted to
you're just not
i just didn't i was reading
relationships i don't even have
attractive
glasses on we're like good looking
um
you weren't busted
that's all you needed
um
for most dudes
it doesn't matter if you're with or
without a person right it's you can tell
who is of course physically good looking
right i could tell who's physically good
looking too yeah but i guess okay so i
guess just a straight answer no yeah i
didn't find you physically good looking
no all right perfect yeah
um
fair enough yeah and then and then i got
to know you and then it was just i
thought you were just the hottest guy
ever
um you're not incorrect yeah so i
thought you were the hottest guy ever
like i loved your posture like your head
shape like everything about you was just
perfect my size eight head yeah perfect
um and then it's more like a 12 but sure
they don't even make hats that size i
know i know you get them custom made
tell the truth fine that's true uh you
wear those [ __ ] what's his name
pharrell hats anyway
because you know they're all [ __ ] big
bucket hats i'm glad he just stopped
that they look like the smokey the
banners but
yeah and made wrong yeah they look
really [ __ ] up
like he shrunk yeah
and then
and then we had our ups and downs in our
relationship and i hated you
and i think i probably did see me pull
huh yeah
so that's pretty sexy and now i think
you're super sexy yeah i think you're
really [ __ ] sexy like yesterday you
put on an actual outfit and i just kept
staring at you the whole time because
i'm like damn papa's [ __ ] fly i told
you and you're hot what the [ __ ] is this
conversation babe what do you mean what
are you trying to what is this topic
what are we talking about here i don't
know we're having a conversation i feel
like i'm talking to an adult taika who
just keeps arguing i'm just backing you
up i started backing up you said you
said you said that i looked attractive
yeah and i said i concur yeah okay fine
well then there did i answer your
question i don't know what you're trying
to get at
where are we why do we have to get go
anywhere
okay fine
fine i'll lay i'll chill out i'm
chilling out chill so there did i answer
your question
no
i didn't answer your question i find you
more attractive than ever than ever yeah
yeah cause they [ __ ] love you so much
that makes me very happy yeah is that
what you wanted yeah okay
that's why i'm asking what are you
trying to get at nothing that's it oh
okay so that's it we wrapped about a
conversation before a young lady i have
but usually if there's like long
i don't know just trying to give you the
floor yeah you're just talking it's like
do you do you do that to your mom your
mom's like how's that what are you
trying to [ __ ] get at [ __ ]
just just like sometimes all right
sometimes i'm sorry i asked maybe i'm a
bad conversation i think you are
sometimes because sometimes i feel like
people are beating around the bush and
i'm like what the [ __ ] you trying to get
at just spit it out what do you what are
you trying to say but some people that
sometimes the bush needs beating
oh all right okay so then uh let's keep
beating it's like i don't know just like
uh people it's like i feel like you're
the person where someone's going for a
walk in the neighborhood like we're
really trying to go
and then they're like
nowhere i'm just i just wanted to just
sure you are i just want to do this for
20 minutes is that okay no that's weird
i know you're trying to go somewhere no
you have an agenda where is it what's
the agenda see tell me that's weird
yeah no um what about you same question
no i think you're super hot the whole
time all the way through
hot except when you're a [ __ ] to me
you're still a hot [ __ ]
but i'm still hot before the [ __ ]
yeah oh hot what's up what's hot to you
uh like what does hot mean
hot means
you look like you want to have sex oh so
you i look like you want to have sex
with me all the time
you look like you don't have sex with me
all the time
and that's what's taught to you that i
just
my loins yearn for you [ __ ] all the
time i mean i know that's not true but
at least you look like it that's cuny i
do every day i want to have sex with you
but i'm just like like during the day
the busiest yeah the peak [ __ ] i'm in
a meeting or whatever and i'm like oh
man that'd be so hot just thinking about
i think it's it's around that time right
now i'm getting turned on just thinking
about it so you're telling me that
should we pause this real quick
and we're back
that's funny so you're telling me you
get hot we're talking about alibaba
sometimes yeah i'm like man [ __ ] this
[ __ ] alibaba [ __ ] let me have some
sex we don't we don't talk to alibaba
it's funny and then uh and then i want
to have sex with you and then you're
busy yeah is it a zip tie on your hoodie
yup it's [ __ ] sick isn't it no yeah
um
yeah but one thing i did want to just
kind of talk about on this podcast
is how we got together because you know
we've gotten a new wave of um
of people
that you know that have discovered me i
guess on instagram and stuff and then
i'll do these q and a's and they're like
wait how did you and bart get together
and then i'm like i find myself
answering this question a lot so i just
figured why not do like an origin story
of how we got together yeah do you um
but you don't really do q and a's huh
i probably should they're so fun are
they yeah they're so cool and like you
get to really connect with people it's
like kind of having um
um it's just fun because they ask
specific questions and you answer and a
lot of people have the same question so
then i'll get a bunch of feedback in my
dms and i start talking to people in dms
and it's just a lot of fun damn i feel
like i'm such a boomer i barely learn
how to share workouts on my stories oh
[ __ ] you know so you know how to add
music to it or we're not there you know
how about text
like i'll see you do three different
fonts and stuff
i'm like wow how did she do that that's
so sad i know i'm such a [ __ ] boomer
that i'm like don't even jump on
tick-tock give me a break and let me
just
keep sharing my workouts and stuff
and then once i feel like i got a grasp
of that maybe i'll do some q and a's do
you know how to do gifs what's that gifs
what's that gif what's that
like the little animated little like
icons sometimes you can do like
literally anything like can i be honest
we have barbell brigade specific ones no
i don't know how to use it shut up dude
i don't even know how to do the barbecue
ones you just under the gif you type in
barbell brigade and it's all of our
logos like dominate humbly the bb stacks
none of that that doesn't ring a bell
like our logo i'm gonna start using them
now that i know we have them dude which
i bet we've probably had for years for
years dude yeah
i'm such a boomer
um so yeah so when i do these q and a's
people will ask like how we got together
some people thought you were friend
zoned the whole time and i'm like no
like um we both we're not into it
so i want to show how we got together
and see also if we remember the right
[ __ ] yeah how far back you want to go
the beginning of the beginning at the
beginning
as far back as we need to
how far are you trying to go all right
i'll tell you from my perspective this
is going to be a
it's going to be a christopher nolan
movie
where it cuts from different
perspectives okay okay
so the first time you said i was on this
gorgeous goddess yeah
um i might get a boner talking about it
oh and you're wearing great pants we
know about great pants girls
so um
this is i'm already getting giddy this
is so cute
this is probably 2003.
three 2004. no no 2004. it has to be
2004 because 2003 i was still in boot
camp um i got out
of boot camp and
my mos school and marine combat training
and i
was i am now really so handsome
i'm now released into the reserves which
means i was allowed to go to school and
do the whole military thing at the same
time so it's got to be 2004.
i remember me and my best friend at the
time
um
we would
do the cheap student thing and not buy
the parking permit
and park
at
the carl's jr that is across the street
it's like a shopping center from the
community college which is a big no-no
there's signs everywhere and there's a
security guard yeah do not park here if
you're going to school
but everyone did it everyone would park
there and like look to see if the
security guard is looking and just book
it right and this security guard always
drank his own piss too
but that's besides the point i told you
that story no
i think he told uh
he told my best friend at the time too
anyways
because i i was with your best friend
and i told him that story no he told me
he told him okay fine
so
um the carl's jr we would park there but
there's also a row of shops in that
shopping plaza that you would walk to to
get to like the crosswalk there was a uh
rios pizza
there's an att at the corner
a gyno
a doctor's office oh right the guy with
the uh mercedes yeah yeah
gynecologists make a hell of money
and then there was
and yeah the rios and then there was a
bookstore
and me and my best friend we started we
went to boot camp together uh mos school
together marine combat training together
and we walked by there together
and i remember us walking by the
textbook store
is when we first saw you and we're like
damn you guys just walked by yeah we're
like damn she's fine wow
then we would talk about you
like what you would talk what do you say
you don't even know me
what do you say that you're hot oh okay
like i like uh so one of the things that
you would always wear all the time would
be like these um like a white wife
beater type thing and your little hip
bones would show and you got flat
stomach it looked all sexy
and then um i still have that i'll wear
that
yeah
and you just look like you wanted to
[ __ ] all the time really to a guy yeah
all right at least to our eyes yeah yeah
yeah yeah and i'm like damn she's hot
and she's like yeah she's hot so we
walked to school and it would do it like
over and over and over again you know um
that's so cute i never once saw you guys
and then you know when we're two yeah
and then you know when you're like
like two dudes are
two dudes or a group of dudes are always
like this right you go to a club oh man
i see her oh yeah yeah oh we should talk
to so much talk to her like you just
kind of do this nudging thing like
someone should do make a move do
something right because you either you
get the number or one of us gets [ __ ]
roasted and it becomes a funny story
later that you could tell the other
homies when you see always talk to talk
to her talk to her and i wanted to talk
to you
but i was just kind of scared a little
bit
why i don't know and then my best friend
were were you normally scared of talking
to chicks
um
so
yes and no i don't know why you
intimidated me
maybe because i'm almost six feet tall
and i have a [ __ ] rbf maybe um
maybe or maybe i felt like he was more
passionate
oh so i don't know i mean we have no
ties to you you know you talk you talk
you talk and he goes i'm gonna do it i'm
like yeah you should you should go do it
what yeah and then so these girls would
do the same thing yeah and then so
uh he ended up going in and talking to
you yeah and i think he told me he asked
you to go out for some coffee or
something
yeah that bookstore was a coffee shop
and i'm like are you serious this is
stupid
that's what you said yeah i was like oh
really you want to go get coffee when i
make coffee all day
what a [ __ ] absolutely
yeah it wasn't that [ __ ] easy cash
but then you guys end up going to get
coffee after a month of him constantly
trying and literally the [ __ ] hook he
likes the challenge though uh that's
probably what it was because if you shut
them down immediately i don't i think it
would have been whatever but i think
since you said what do you i think since
you came back with some attitude he goes
oh i got something to work with yeah no
uh he he so do you want me to give you
that that perspective of what happened
there yeah tell me so he comes into the
bookstore and it's peak season so this
the where i worked um i was already
going to cal state uh lay i think at
that point yeah um
doing that full-time and then working
there part-time
and um
in during the so we sold college
bookstore it was a college bookstore
textbook store but on the off season
because you know in the beginning of
each quarter or semester everyone needs
to get their materials and it is booming
it would be like like three or four cash
registers all day lines out the wazoo
all day there's a line yeah um
yep and so that's just the first week
but then after everyone has their books
you don't need books anymore so it's
completely empty so the way that that
business ran was on the off season then
we're just selling coffee and we're
making fresh juices
and it was a perfect job for me because
it's so dead i get to study so all i
would do is study and i would probably
get maybe 10 customers a day or like
within my work period and i loved it so
it was peak season and everyone's
getting their college books and um this
guy walks in with his friend i don't i
don't recall what his friend looked like
it could have been you i don't know
and then he just starts flirting with me
and i'm like he would be like oh yeah
this like he would be talking about the
book but you can tell it's very
flirtatious and he's just trying to make
too many comments
um did he come in peak season he came in
downtime uh peak season i think okay and
like he was just asking about books but
just being like extra friendly and i
just was not about it um and i think i
was probably joking back but super
sarcastically
and then i think he came back again
during peak season so that means he had
to wait in line multiple times for
[ __ ] who knows how long because these
lines are [ __ ] long out the wazoo
yeah and then that's when he starts
asking me um
like to hang out or do whatever you know
and then that's when i give him the
attitude of like he's like well we
should just go get coffee sometime or
whatever but the way he said it
to me just felt jokey like i was just
like
this is weird that's also him now i know
right in retrospect that is him yeah uh
cause he also doesn't know how to just
put on the table and get scared to get
hurt right but it's always a joke it's
kind of lukewarm yes i was like oh okay
so you're inviting me to go get coffee
when i make coffee all day i'm like that
doesn't sound fun at all
and then uh
uh
completely shot him down and he would
like after that he would just keep
trying to come in and like just keep
talking to me and stuff and like make
small conversation and little by little
he started winning me over and it got to
the point though where he made a t-shirt
with my face on it oh that's dope you
don't you didn't what you didn't see i
remember yeah i remember he told me was
gonna do that that was dope yeah so he
made that and i was like what the [ __ ]
this guy just won't quit you know it was
like a month of me just like
not into it yeah you know and like um
i just wasn't about it persistence is
important yeah and then like he was just
about it and i'm like oh [ __ ] like um
that's funny like this dude is like
really funny and like he doesn't give a
[ __ ] about about what people think and
i'm like that's really cool and i like
that he was really persistent i wasn't
trying to like prolong it for any
specific reason i was just like not into
it uh but the more i was not into it the
more he would show his true colors and
the more i was like oh that's really
cool like he's a really cool dude and
he's going to school and stuff
and i remember um
like
now because he's introduced into my life
now i like i see when he is walking by
and then i see you you are with him and
then i would i remember seeing you and
going like wow that guy like has a
really cool like look to him you have a
cool look yeah like i mean you were very
bummy looking i was wearing the same
clothes every day yeah but not the same
i get it yeah the same size i had seven
of the same like shirts yeah yeah and so
what i liked about that um i thought you
had a really cool look because you had
this
like this look of i'm not here to [ __ ]
around i'm not here to impress you i'm
here to do work yeah and that's what i
really liked about um how you looked and
even him like both of you guys look the
same um
like you would walk
in with like faded [ __ ] black socks
or not walk in but walk by because yes
you were parking illegally
um but you have to cross my coffee shop
to get to school or get back to your car
so i would see you frequently and this
is when you had your um your gold or
silver this is still to this day we
[ __ ] talk about it tacoma toyota
tacoma yeah and i would see you walk by
and i would even see you drive off with
it was it lifted it was lifted yeah hell
yeah
and uh you had i think like an army
backpack
yeah i had a uh like a camo backpack
yeah so at that time in the in the
marine corps they're uh
issuing the molly packs and molly pack
is like an external plastic frame pack
and then it's cool because uh you have
the main pack that you could stuff and
like be out in the wilderness for like
seven to fourteen days then there's a
day pack that's stuck to it
and then so that thing detaches from
that that's what you were using
um but i didn't think much of it right i
was just like oh he has a cool look and
you were you were jacked yeah um
you were buffer but like you just had
like this impeccable posture like i had
never seen that like you just walked
around and like
you just had this this like i don't give
a [ __ ] about anyone else type presence
and i really like that and that's very
true and didn't and not liked it where i
like
focused on it but i definitely was aware
that that i was like whoa that guy's
different but that's it just ended there
um
and
eventually me and your best friend at
that time uh we get together
and it becomes more serious now and um
yeah we hang out more what actually won
you over like at the when you guys
actually had the coffee date was it like
good conversation sparks flew or like
what made you go
okay this is pretty cool um
so i like how heavily he pursued me
and i like persistence yeah so uh he's
willing to put in the work yeah he's
willing to put in the work he didn't
care about what other people thought
like to put a picture of me on your face
yeah like i come from an era where guys
don't do that [ __ ] because now you're
sprung you know like you don't want to
appear to be like whipped on someone you
know like to show that you're really
into a person for a male at that time
and i'm talking about early 2000s uh was
a sign of weakness like you're not a man
if you're pursuing a chick that hard
yeah that's just what i grew up with
um so for me to see the complete
opposite was very refreshing
so it was super refreshing and it was
very creative and um
and i was very intrigued
so so that what was what piqued my
interest and started opening me up to
that possibility um and then when he
took me out it was like this really cool
obviously now right korean um like
coffee shop and it was really quaint it
was super cute and the conversation was
cool because he wasn't an idiot and he
had his head on straight and you know he
had goals of like
um
you know this is the jc but he wanted to
go into sc and he wanted just to do so
many different things and he was a very
good conversationalist
um
yeah he just wasn't an idiot he had his
head on right and um
so yeah he just kind of checked box
checked off a lot of the boxes that at
least for my standard at that point yeah
and he liked going to the gym and like
he had a good physique he was taller i
don't know there were just so many
things that um that i liked about him
that i just liked you know and then um
very quickly in the relationship he
introduces me into like his family and
stuff and they completely accepted me
and like already loved me off the bat
and i loved them off the bat and i was
like whoa like your family dynamic is
really cool like i remember having like
early on in the relationship like having
like joining them for dinner yeah and i
was like whoa like this is
this is weird like i didn't in a good
way yeah where i'm like oh [ __ ] this is
like really serious yeah like i would
never
want to introduce anybody to my family
until i knew it was
anything you know so
so prior to him i probably only
introduced my family to maybe
one other boyfriend at that time oh yeah
yeah and that was only after like a year
of being together wow
yeah
um
so yeah so yeah we become a thing we
become a couple and then i get
introduced to his friends and you're
part of that circle
and um
and yeah i don't think anything of
anybody there obviously because they're
they're the hobbies they're homies
and everyone's cool but like um
i'm not looking at anyone specifically
you're not looking at anyone for
anything you know i'm just like there to
hang out yeah
and uh we would we would go to like
movie nights we went shooting we would
um go on double dates and [ __ ] like i
remember you and i
oh the four of us we we like went on
double dates multiple times and [ __ ] yes
um
and just i just found you like
i didn't really like you very much
yeah you were always a homie that was
always trying to like preach
like you're always trying to set the
like like if there there was always
something that the the group was arguing
about or debating about right there was
that group liked to debate a lot there
was always some type of debate always
happening but it was never super serious
and it was over the stupidest [ __ ]
and then um you would come in like like
this righteous guy always like
setting things straight
feelings i'm sad for myself oh wow i
didn't know i was doing that but maybe
they don't see it that way now that i
look back and i was i was oh yeah yeah
so um it always felt like you were that
guy you know yeah
um because i hate
you know like the worst advice is when
it's unsolicited
you know yeah and then i'm like [ __ ] i
was that guy god damn it anything
this is amongst your friends though yeah
but i look back and i'm like
i was that guy yeah for sure you were
like and then you would like you had
braces at this time and you would eat
and like
you oh just watching you eat for some
reason always stuck out and it was just
so disgusting there's so many souvenirs
left behind it was just so disgusting
you would do this thing where you were
talking yeah and like you talk with your
mouth open yeah and then you have braces
so it's stuck in there and then you
drink water and you would go
and you would swish the water around i
guess to clean your teeth and i'm like
yo this fool's nasty and then you would
fart all the time and you just you had
like the lowest class of that whole
group like you were foul dude i was
really yeah oh [ __ ] so it was you first
and then it was my ex-boyfriend we were
the two worst you guys were the worst
but it ties into us not giving a [ __ ]
yeah which is why what i liked right
yeah and then like the reason why i
dressed like a bum at school it was
always clean clean and present look like
you stunned because you always had like
your hair cut yeah and i never had
wrinkled clothes everything was just
really chill it was worn out i knew what
i looked like when i dressed up so i'm
like i don't need to impress anybody you
know i'm here to study and then i'm
gonna go to the gym and [ __ ] crush my
life
and then so like
um i just as long as i look clean and
presentable that was cool i didn't feel
like i had to like steez it up you know
yeah and that's what i liked with both
of you guys
i felt that you had enough to offer
intellectually
that the rest was just um
it was just like
my new details like it just didn't
[ __ ] matter so that's what it really
attracted me to that um
so yeah like and then when the homies
would get together obviously there's a
lot of guys and i was the only one that
i i was i guess he was the only one that
had a girlfriend at that time no one
else
had a chick for whatever reason yeah and
um what i liked about him was that what
you see is what you got
um he would talk about how much porn he
watched he would talk about so he was
very open about everything yeah so even
if there was a girl that every like all
the guys were taught like if she'd walk
by they'd be like damn she's hot like he
would partake in that and i didn't mind
because i'm just like um
i'd rather have you do it to my face
then you give me your best foot full
like to give me this one face but then
behind my back you're that other way
yeah so um
but what if someone a dude does that out
of respect
does
true that too but for me that was my
reasoning as to like i prefer that
because you again remember like um i'm
coming from an era where everything's a
front
everyone's friending about how they feel
about women how like or dudes at least
it was everything was a front like you
got a dress fly as a front you know what
i mean like they're just too many fronts
yeah so for me to hear that and i had
never heard anyone speak like that i'm
like oh [ __ ] finally someone's not
fronting i see so
yes they're doing it maybe out of
respect but for me i'm like give me
something new yeah you know and that was
it that makes sense um but then one
thing that stuck out to me as that
conversation was happening and it
wouldn't be super vulgar like no one was
like super disrespectful and like if
there was a hot chick it would stop at
like damn she is hot hot and that would
that would be it it wasn't like damn let
me [ __ ] bend her over like it was
never like that like so even that was
super respectful
but i would notice you
um
didn't even care
like they would have that conversation
and then like you would just glance and
you'd just get back to it so you had
like this righteousness to you or that i
perceived as righteous where like you
didn't even soup to that level so i was
like oh that is very interesting um i
also feel like there are
there are inside thoughts and outside
thoughts
yeah you know yeah um yeah but for me i
like that the outside was being put on
the out the inside was being put on the
outside because it was just i didn't get
exposed to that because on the inside
i'm probably give me life
give me like 10 seconds in the elevator
with her you know yeah
but then on the outside i'm like i don't
need to
what's that gonna do but why would but
not like so for me i saw that as why why
not partake these are your homies this
is the comfort you know like this is
this is the all doors are closed and no
one's gonna judge you like you can be
you i also like being real so i'm like
are we gonna have an orgy
like if we're gonna talk like this then
are all five of our dudes gonna bone
chicks together like this yeah if not
then you know because like to me
everything is
you you you walk your talk right or you
talk where you're gonna walk yeah so if
the dude is like yeah i'ma [ __ ] you up
whatever in the parking lot right i'm
like
let's just fight yeah right yeah so if
you don't want to fight
then let's not talk yeah so when people
are saying oh bend over do all these
things i'm like are you really going to
are you really going to bend her over
because if you are i'll bring my chicken
well i'll bend it we'll have an orgy
yeah but if we're not then
that's how i viewed it yeah yeah um
but yeah i just saw that you didn't
participate in that and and i was i
thought that was very interesting
because boys will be bullies right
that's the saying yep
so when i saw that i was like oh that's
interesting but i didn't think much of
it
so um i end up being with this guy for
about three years
and um you and i are never really close
there's never a real situation that you
and i need to like hang out or do
whatever like i thought you're a [ __ ]
too um yeah probably because i didn't
like you right so [ __ ] up um i don't
know if other people probably thought it
was issue but i didn't like a couple of
the guys there we actually did hang out
quite a bit though because
your boyfriend was my best friend um but
we didn't have a reason to really talk
do you know what i mean oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he was always
in a group yeah yeah the group the group
spent a lot of time together
and i mean you even met my mom right
which is not your boyfriend not your
boyfriend's mom just because of like a
wedding um
ready
no no but even besides that like you
would like let's say if me and my best
friend had to
go to the airport or do something like
you would take us like so we actually
spent a lot of time
together
two other people are in the picture yeah
um
uh so yeah and then towards the end of
our relationship it just was more just
him and i and like you weren't in the
picture very much and like there were
only some friends that we would kind of
hang out with and then he would hang out
with my friends more too a little bit i
think that's when it was getting close
to probably like
transferring time so you know people
spend two to three years in community
college yeah and it's getting serious
and then oh okay this home is going to
long beach yeah this home is going over
here this home is going over here so
it's like people were getting more
serious and more um
uh like involved than whatever they're
doing yeah that's literally what
happened um one of the homies is going
to be a firefighter now the other one's
going about to go to pace academy yeah
that was literally that point yeah
because i remember you were doing like a
medical internship um that summer before
even going to school i think at sc ucla
was it at ucla yeah okay ucla and i
remember like we all drove to just pay
you a visit because i think you were
like living out there for a little bit
oh yeah when you came with the other
homies
uh and you saw my cousin yeah yeah yeah
yeah that was the ucla apartment yeah
um and then so yeah like we just started
seeing the homies less and less and less
and then he transferred into sc
you didn't even come with
uh
you didn't even come with um your
boyfriend at the time
at that time we could have been broken
up i'm not i'm kind of getting the
timelines a little bit yeah me too it is
a long time well
but um but yeah so i was already living
on my own
towards the end of that relationship i
had just moved out of my house
um you graduated college you're working
now yeah i'm already pretty set yeah and
um yeah i'm living with my girlfriends
and he's doing the sc thing he's hanging
out more with just a different group of
like sc people and i'm like whoa like he
started kind of changing i started
changing
he was getting really in touch with this
korean roots i remember yeah and i was
just like this is weird man like i don't
even know this person anymore and i
don't like how he's talking to me i
don't like how i feel around him he
would bring some of his like korean club
homies over um
and then he would it would tell like me
and the other homies to call him hyung
and i'm like first of all i'm not
opposed to that because i grew up in
cerritos had a lot of korean older
homies and i called them young's but i
don't know this [ __ ] and then we
have another one of the other homies
he's like fourth generation japanese
and he's like i don't even speak
japanese
i'm definitely not gonna speak korean
that's tight
um so yeah so that relationship just
kind of um i break up with him
so we break up and this is
i want to say in november
but i have all of you guys still as
friends because like we ended up um just
kind of getting close
okay so um we end up breaking up and
this is around the holiday season i
remember in november
and i was just so devastated and not
like really devastated but i think i was
more down on myself
for allowing
myself to become a different person in
the relationship was this like 2007 2008
maybe
2008
because then we get together oh okay um
right
yeah cause i i remember like
or maybe it was even before november
because i remember doing halloween with
just my friends and and none of you guys
were involved in that yeah
maybe it was maybe it was before then
actually then but maybe we were just
kind of talking back and forth trying to
maybe fix it i don't know
yeah cause i remember doing halloween in
west hollywood
and you were like i just was with my own
friends yeah yeah
um
so yeah maybe i was just already [ __ ]
up i was just like man like
it just got to the point in the
relationship where i just thought he was
just a complete [ __ ] and like i
thought i was a complete loser for
[ __ ] like allowing someone just to be
an [ __ ]
um
and then uh i'm living on my own or with
my friends
and um it's thanksgiving now and i'm
just bummed like i was hanging out doing
like single life [ __ ] like going to
clubs doing work like all that [ __ ]
um staying up late because i had just
moved out so that was so fun right yeah
but i just was like this is so whack
um
and it was thanksgiving
and uh one of the homies
uh mike remember he like he's he's very
much about like spending family time
together yeah and he like hit me up he's
like hey what are you doing like for the
holidays or whatever and i'm like dude i
think i'm just gonna stay and just stay
indoors and just kind of not do anything
and then he's like no you can't do that
like come through like you know you can
come hang out with us like he's not
going to be here like dude like just
come hang out with all of us we're going
to be here i was like nah man that's
going to be weird like it's all good
like i just i don't really feel like up
to it
and then i remember um you and him came
to my house with the plate of like
thanksgiving dinner
um and then i remember going like
like oh that's so nice like that's so
nice of bart um
and um i think we just talked a little
bit and you guys are trying to hang out
and like trying to get me to go out and
i'm like nah dude thank you so much i'm
just you guys knew i was bummed
uh and i just we just left it at that
and at that time i was working at the
bank too
oh i remember how we all started hanging
out
so um
that summer
the summer before that
um
my best friend since he was getting
really acquainted with his korean roots
he went to korea
oh right he went to korea for a few
months good point yeah he went to korea
for a few months that's why i didn't see
him and then so he was like hey like
hang out with the homies they'll take
care of you and that's when we started
hanging out without him because i
remember
hanging out alone
a lot more without him yeah but still
not one-on-one but just like the homies
yeah so it became where it's like all of
us had direct contact with you and it
wasn't weird yeah yeah yeah it's like
okay me and me it makes sense me and
mike gonna go do something uh let's see
if gio wants to come or me and this guy
are gonna go do something let's see if
gio wants to come good point because um
yeah yeah because i cuz it all leads to
us going snowboarding later right and it
wasn't not it was not
not normal yeah
to
see if gio wanted to go snowboarding
right right yeah i remember oh yeah he
was in korea good call doing his own
thing and then so we were already
hanging out so i think that's why like
you know in our group it made sense in
our friend's circle at the time um
mike was the most family oriented yeah
and like the the
i always felt like we're like the lost
boys yeah where a lot of us didn't have
like tight families like that and so
when mike would spend time
with like this side of the family for
halloween christmas or thanksgiving he
always invited me yeah and then if he
goes to like long beach he always
invited me so like i like i'm so
thankful for him because he you know
brought me into his family like so much
yeah that makes sense because when you
say that i'm like yeah why were we at
raves together and like he wasn't there
yeah because we were here we went to
that one uh we went to edie's
mansion party remember that oh right
what's a crazy ass that mansion party
was crazy that was crazy so yeah oh my
god i forgot about that yeah it was that
summer and i think uh
mike's brother was a uh he's a he was
becoming a really known dj or something
and he told us about this party that
this party was like at a secret mansion
location in hollywood hills yeah we had
to meet at this weird random [ __ ]
parking lot where this unmarked van
picked us all up and remember those
chinese there's a shuttle yeah remember
the chinese uh they look like they were
like in their 50s and they were rolling
off their [ __ ]
ass yeah they looked in my pants they
were wearing uh sunglasses yeah i'm like
how the [ __ ] did because they didn't
even speak english no mike how the [ __ ]
did you guys hear about this [ __ ] cuz
we're in our 20s and it makes sense
remember we saw um not l bundy but the
son from the married with children
walking his [ __ ] dog in hollywood
randomly yeah yeah so um
you said something about that night
uh once we got together but um
so our friend mike that always wanted us
to hang out always wanted everyone to
drink yeah so he would comes in with
four drinks all the time he would drop
fat cash just to get everyone just
feeling good drinking having a good time
and i remember at that time i was always
thinking about like like fitness and
[ __ ] so um i was probably on a diet
where i wasn't eating very much
so then he comes with shots and and um
beer mainly beer he was a beer guy
i remember drinking and i think i drank
too much that i like blacked out you
started throwing up in the bushes oh my
god and you were taking care of me yeah
it was me
mike two others i think and then mike's
brother doe was there too yeah
oh my god but you were like you said
that you felt like super
like obligated to take care of me yeah
because he's you're like
my best friend's uh
my best friend's woman you know yeah so
i felt like family because i was really
tight with him that's cuny although even
at that time though
me and him started to drift apart yeah
like
me and him we got really tight in high
school
um to the point where we were going to
join the marine corps together
i was actually always going to go the
army route because i went i came from uh
a military school that was more army
based so i was very familiar with the
army and that's what i wanted to do
um but his next door neighbor did you
ever meet him across across the street
so he was uh going through marine corps
officer training and he would always
just preach about
like how dope the marine corps was
and then you know i have the whole story
of what's going on
i'm hearing a lot so let me just go to
every single recruit center
and by myself to see
what fits me and then i go in the army i
go in the navy and oh you want to see
the world and it feels like some used
car salesmen you know and i go in the
marine corps one i'm like hello
hello looking around no one's even there
and finally this guy crawls up from
underneath the desk and he's like wiping
his eye boogers he goes yeah you enjoy
the marine corps i'm like this is my
dude that's so funny i just like i don't
like real [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah even
like real [ __ ] like i would see the army
dude i'm like you got slicked back hair
and you're supposed to fight in the
bushes
i'm like you look too pretty to be
[ __ ] you know and this guy he was
like kind of like chunky not chunky like
like like overweight but just he just
looked thick like he just looked like
he would wreck your ass you know and
then he's also sleeping under the desk
because he's tired from some for some
reason yeah you know i'm like hell yeah
and so we joined together and in
the
in boot camp
it's really tough right it's non-stop
there's a schedule every single minute
of the day from like 5am all the way
until you go to sleep
and it brings out a lot of different
sides of people you know when people say
i'm [ __ ] i try
i'll fight you whatever right and then
when [ __ ] hits the fan and your home is
getting jumped
if you whether or not you jump in really
shows who you are you know
and so when [ __ ] really hit the fan
all the stuff that i thought me and him
connected on
um it wasn't the case
and then so i started to feel like this
weird like
oh man i don't think we really like
are who
i don't think we were like soul mate
brothers the way we said we were
you know and over and over again like
things would happen and i felt like i
had to step in and almost felt like
i had to like take care of him at
certain points like even the even the um
even the summer before we shipped out do
you remember we got into that big ass
car accident oh that was before my time
oh you did tell me about it oh okay so
oh yeah he was with another girl but
yeah
we were we were racing to go watch a
movie right i'm in my best friend's car
the other two homies on the other car
were racing we come up this this hill
and uh
the car started spinning we smash into a
traffic i mean a street light the street
light bends over and um
it crushes the car
firefighters have to pull us out my
friend was knocked out i'm kind of going
in and out of consciousness
we get put in a ambulance take us to sc
county hospital
i was probably doing hella shrugs at
that time so my neck was a little bit
stronger so i was able to like
i was able i actually didn't get
released i was just like i'm tired of
eating jello so i i walked out the front
door but me and his family were so tight
where i called his older brother because
i don't want to bother my parents i'm
like yo can you pick me up yeah sure so
i called them and i walked out the front
door with my ass cheeks hanging out with
my with the gown oh my god i didn't even
ask for my clothes back or nothing i
just literally like did the movie thing
like pull the [ __ ] i'm like i'm tired
of [ __ ] so i would just pull the [ __ ]
[ __ ] the shits out
and i just walked out the front door
and then when i came back because he was
still so traumatized like he would
constantly throw up he couldn't keep
food down
it was we're about to ship out in like a
week or two his mom was like
hey um
can you can you delay your shipment
you're shipping out with him so you got
because i trust him being with you and
we're brothers you know so i'm all right
let's do it let's oh yeah didn't you say
you had a forego like a bonus oh yeah i
scored really high on the asvab so i got
a pretty sick bonus
um but it's attached that shipping date
and to that job
but then he's my brother so i'm like
even my dad that was so stupid he goes
you're gonna give away that much money
it was like a signing bonus and then on
my knives might be like 10 grand i think
it was like 10 grand or something and
then he was like for a [ __ ] 18 19
year old yeah yeah and my dad you're so
[ __ ] dumb and i'm like i don't care
brother's over everything yeah um but i
forgot to go to the military with him
and uh i think that was the start of
like a declining friendship
of
feeling like
i had to take care of him
and then it wasn't really like
equals anymore yeah it just felt like um
he wasn't as like
i don't know if the word is like macho
or
alpha but it felt like that
you know bummer yeah and then so and
then through boot camp you just see it
uglier uglier sides we go to mls school
you see ugly other side so that was that
probably created the biggest
divide yeah and then going back into the
civilian world you know we were all kind
of preachy for some reason you know all
five six of us
so he would still be preachy and then
i'm looking at him with these eyes like
[ __ ] i've seen how you are i've
seen the real you you know and you're
still talking like this
so i think naturally in the group it
used to be me and him that were best
friends but then um i started hanging
out with mike moore more more and more
yeah and then he would get like jealous
too like he'd be like like yo dude what
happened
how come here at mike's house and then
and it just so happened that mike also
lived right next to elac is deli
community college oh right so i'm like
uh he literally lives like two minutes
away it's easy for me to go after school
they're all friends right we're not
competing yeah it's easy for him to go
after school straight to his house yeah
um
but yeah and then so i think there's
already slowly that divide so i think
even when you and him got into the
picture it was already me and him yeah
because it didn't feel like you guys
kept saying you guys are best friends
but didn't really feel like it and jk
started
so my time was split with like probably
the beginning of my
other best friend which is joe but we
just connected just on the art form of
comedy yeah not really tight tight yet
because even joe would view me in the
other guy's best friends yeah you know
so he would view that as best friends
but i think that was probably literally
just the start where i'm starting to
separate from him and then me and joe
started spending a ton of time together
like filming it more and more and more
yeah
yeah i remember getting those video
clips from you guys and going man this
is so stupid
what the hell are they sending me
um so then
yes then him and i we break up
and yeah we were hanging out a lot more
because he was away and then um
uh you guys came over to give me that
thanksgiving plate and i was like wow
that's really cool and i it was it was
it warmed my heart so much to know that
people cared about me like that
yeah and everyone i think just started
viewing it viewing you not as the homies
girl but just another homie now yeah
super cool yeah and then um
i don't know he got so far gone in his
korean roots that like he kind of
started excluding himself from that
circle so it kind of worked out nicely
that i was getting accepted into it more
and he was just kind of like moving away
yeah we would [ __ ] have a bonfire at
the beach and he's showing up in slacks
yeah he's so weird i'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on dude yeah it
was weird like this was like trying to
look like a uh
like a k-town player you know because
everyone in the k-town club like that at
that time i'm like why are you wearing
[ __ ] this is weird
loafers yeah
to dock well or it was weird man it was
so weird like he would uh so he would go
and he'd host his friends like at
different korean clubs while we were
still together and i would find like
girls numbers and [ __ ] all over like
like in his clothes and his pants and
stuff because oh it's not for me like
you know it's
it's you know i'm trying to hook them
the girls up with my homies or whatever
and i'm like but
i know your style like i know um i
didn't think anything foul happened but
who knows right um
so then yeah we break up we're not doing
our thing
the homies are hanging out more and we
would go snowboarding and one of those
excuse me one of those times um all the
homies were like dude let's go i was
supposed to be mike richard kevin you me
and i think you were picking everyone
like you were picking up people one by
one
and that was the last one i was just
asking everyone yeah yeah because i
think i was the one furthest out because
at that time i was living in alhambra
and i guess from all hamburger you just
jump on maybe the 60 or something the 10
yeah the 10 and then you go straight
there yeah yeah so i was the last one
getting picked up
and then i get it it's all just supposed
to meet at your house oh it's right off
the freeway okay yeah it was right off
the freeway so we're just all gonna meet
at your house right okay so then one by
one i start getting texts of like people
dropping out and you go like oh [ __ ] i'm
out front and i remember looking out my
window
because my room i was running a room
with my friends at that time i look out
my window and it faces the street and
your blue truck you're in there in your
blue truck
and i was like oh [ __ ] like i have to
get stuck with you
and i'm like this is gonna be so awkward
like what were you thinking because i'm
like i don't like this person everyone
was dropping out
and then it ended up being
you me
and richard yeah
and then um so i'm like you know richard
loves snowboarding yeah he's one of
those guys that once he starts doing i
mean dives deep into it so i'm like okay
that's tight like three's company
whatever let's let's roll you know and
then we get to your house
and i'm like texting them
i'm like
yo are you coming and i'm like oh yeah i
also remember richard's a vietnamese
lager i'm like [ __ ]
if we say i think it was like seven or
eight am i just supposed to show up at
like
11 or something
so i'm like damn it
ah [ __ ] it i'm already here you know i'm
like it already took me so much on the
holidays because probably i don't know
like december november or december i'm
like if it's already in the holidays and
i got up anyways and snowboard clothes
aren't easy to put on i'm already half
in it i'm like [ __ ] it you know so
that's why i asked you if you still
wanted to go
and then i think you're like
[ __ ] it yeah yeah
and i remember like i was still getting
ready and you were just in your car like
i thought you were going to come out and
you were in your car and i think at that
point you were taking singing lessons so
i was like what the [ __ ] is he doing was
that was i was like yeah
and it was [ __ ] loud and i'm like
this is weird as [ __ ] and i'm like all
right [ __ ] it
it's you and i in the truck and we're
driving up to big bear and stuff and i
remember like
we just got to talking
like like i just made an effort to just
talk to you because i'm like what else
am i gonna do like he is a friend he's
not really a dick but like i just find
him annoying like let me just strike up
a conversation and i think we started
talking about like my relationship and
stuff and like i was feeling about it
and it felt so natural talking to you
like it felt really nice it felt like um
even though you were his homie like you
you kept a very neutral position and you
were like explaining like his side and
you were trying to understand my side
and like you were really just trying to
hear me out for whatever i was saying
and i was like whoa this is really cool
i don't even remember what we talked
about to be honest um
well i don't remember the words
but i remember the feeling right yeah
[ __ ] maya angelou yeah like people
won't remember what you say they'll
always remember how you made them feel
yeah
um and i remember feeling really
comfortable and i felt really natural
talking to you at that point and i
remember this line specifically you know
because i just felt so much like i felt
like i had bottled up so much um because
i just didn't know how to deal with what
i was going through in that relationship
because i had just
like that relationship made me grow so
much because i went from like
strictly being career driven to just
being super
single
and not wanting kids and not wanting to
do things traditionally to now going
like oh wait have i been viewing all of
this stuff wrong like that family is
really cool and this guy
yeah like like he has a really good head
on his shoulders and like he has like a
bright future and like i can see
building with this i'm like man maybe
should i change my percep my pers like
my goals my personal goals
and then that's when i really started
considering marriage and settling down
and family and taking that traditional
route
so when that ended it really [ __ ] me
up because i'm like holy [ __ ] i lost
myself in that relationship and i hated
that
and i really hated my not hating myself
but i was disappointed at myself because
i always like
i was i was always so proud of myself
for sticking to who i've always been
which is like this very independent
person who doesn't need anybody for
anything
who knows what she wants and goes after
it regardless of
obstacles like that's always been me
so the fact that i wasn't that and i let
i let myself be so vulnerable that like
this person was able to like infiltrate
my goals to like make me want something
different like i was i hated it
so then
um i got to talking to you about all of
that stuff and i got to open and it felt
like you really understood and like you
were like
it just felt good i don't know like it
just felt like we flowed so nicely in
conversation and just like the feeling i
was getting from you i don't know if you
were getting that from me but obviously
you were because we're together
but this is the line that i remember
like
this feeling of like this big sigh of
relief after we talked like i had this
huge sigh and i just went like
ah i'm like man bart like this gives me
so much hope you know to know that
there's people out there um like you for
me
because i didn't consider you
uh like a candidate yeah like you're not
because you're the homie yeah you know
but i was just like oh [ __ ] if bart
exists and bart has his level of
maturity and insight um
and like i have this feeling with him
i'm like that's tight there's hope like
i can i can have that again with someone
else
you know yeah and then i just moved on
and then then at that point that just
solidified a friendship for me i didn't
even remember like
any specific lines
i do remember it felt like you're in a
bad place
and i just felt like i'm like oh man
like
i don't think
like i just wanted to try to like
make it feel like it was okay for you
like whatever it was it just felt like
you i don't know i felt like you were
being tied up somehow and i just feel
like oh man that sucks i'm like it's i
don't think it's like that it's but
maybe like this you know it's more like
this and then you're like i can see you
kind of found it like loosen up a little
bit
and then i think that was that yeah it
was that yeah and it really ended at
that and what's crazy is we didn't
we i remember it was just small talk
it was just gonna be like like homie
talk like oh cool hey you want to eat
something later super homie talk and
then it but then it was
that's when it got snowed in though yeah
that's what i'm getting at so i remember
we were driving and that was happening
and i remember saying that and feeling
that and going like damn like like i
like everything i was holding in and all
these knots that i had in my heart like
they just started kind of loosening it
loosening up and i found a lot of
clarity within our conversation that i
was like cool
i'm in a place to move on now like at
that point i just felt like good yeah
and then we get snowed in and then i'm
like because snow storm hits to the
point where uh going into big bear it's
a one lane up one lane down it snowed in
so hard
that the cars couldn't move no
and didn't know if he had chains nothing
nothing and we're back or bumper to
bumper front and back so no one could
bust a u-turn and leave because it's
cars going up in and out
and remember uh like the those guys in
those neon jackets are just walking down
the sideways just going like you're
hanging off yeah turn it off turn it off
because you're going to be here for a
while so we're like oh [ __ ] and i
remember being stuck there for like four
hours yeah
stuck for hours just like talking about
life now yeah like you were you
introduced me to khalil i think uh he
was like a taiwanese like army
yeah yeah yeah and then i was like whoa
this is actually tight and like and i
think because we had that prior
conversation it just felt like cool i
just felt like two homies having a
conversation but like we were vibing on
so many different levels and still like
i didn't think anything of it i was just
like done no wonder we like we're all
homies yeah because this is what homies
do we just click yeah and then after
those four hours of just talking about
[ __ ] and just laughing and just i
don't know just being
just being friends yeah we finally get
to the mountain we snowboard um
we come back down no big deal we eat we
hang out a little bit but still nothing
yeah uh nothing for me at least
and then i go home
and then the next day
or the next couple of days i think i'm
just like i don't know why i can't stop
thinking about you
and then um i don't know i remember we
were chat in like that a little bit the
aim and just talk because we we
connected so much yeah that we started
talking like yeah just wait you know
like back when you had aim if you signed
on and you saw like the five usual
suspects you just say hey what's up to
everyone yeah hey what's up what's up
what's up and just see who responds if
they're even responding and so you end
up being one of my usual suspects now
hey what's going on you know yeah we
would just talk and then that kind of
turned into like a text back and forth
yeah
and then um i'm like [ __ ] this is so
weird i don't know why i can't stop
thinking about this dude
and then i remember
and i think this is the moment that i
realized like i really liked you
um
was i was gonna go on another
snowboarding trip with my friends we had
ran out of cabin and um
and i think
and i don't know for some reason like he
we just had such a good time that i'm
like damn i really want bart to come on
this one
and that no one else like none of the
other homies i really cared about
and uh it was gonna be like six of us on
my side
and then it was gonna and i'm like man i
really want to invite bart
like he loves this so much and it felt
like you were just so free like it felt
like you got something different out of
the snowboarding trip that we had that
you hadn't gotten before i don't know
maybe i was convincing myself something
else
and i was so nervous but i asked you if
you wanted to come and i was like kind
of going back and forth for a long time
like
should i invite him should i not i'm
like is it weird and i'm like why am i
why do i want to invite him like this is
weird and i was just fighting it for
myself so much and i think i was trying
to justify it as but he just had such a
good time i know he'll love my friends
my friends are [ __ ] cool yeah um and
then i was just like ah [ __ ] it like i
told myself like there's nothing there
uh i don't know why i'm so nervous i'm
making it a big deal just [ __ ] invite
him so i texted you like hey we're all
gonna do like a cabin or whatever
and then you replied and you were like
no i really can't like i would love to
but i have this like orthodontic
appointment i remember the phone call i
was literally upstairs of the balcony of
my orthodontist and like we're leaving
whatever whatever and i'm like
i really wanted to go too
but i was like oh [ __ ] i have to do this
and then i think i had a couple other
things i needed to do and i couldn't oh
you know what it was i was so
heartbroken that that
that whole like two weeks
um
it was christmas break
so i
left ucla and then me and joe had plans
where i was gonna crash at his place
um and we were gonna do a right fest and
also ship out um all of our merch like
all of the all of the like the three
t-shirts that we had yeah and so i
didn't know any of that yeah so i
couldn't
abandon him if we
already agreed to all that you know yeah
i didn't know that and i just felt so
sad yeah and that like
and it even that didn't make sense like
[ __ ] why are you so sad like i didn't
even i i didn't even know that i'd liked
you that much
i was just like oh man like the homie
can't huh come like i really want the
homie to be here you know that was going
to keep me warm in the covers damn the
homie cam comes yeah and i remember um
on that trip too like i was just like
half in like like not really there you
know because i'm like man i kind of wish
bart was here
and then that like when we came back
down or whatever like we just talked a
lot via text yeah and i remember like
it just got to the point where um i
remember i would text you during like my
shift at work i remember walking the
floor
and um
and i was like okay can i tell you
something and then that's when i told
you that i can't stop thinking about you
and then you reply that it was the same
thing look at me making the moves all
the [ __ ] time
um and then this is during like
i think like motorola razor or like
blackberry days yeah i remember texting
was not fun yeah and then uh you you
wrote that to me
and you you said like you too and i was
like oh [ __ ]
and then um i go home
and i'm like okay well now what
like you're really saying i remember uh
during this time
because i was staying at joe's place
i was like hey joe
you're not gonna believe this
but i'm like i think
me and geo
like each other oh my god and we're
talking
and then joe's like
secret lovers
he just thought it was the funniest
thing ever yeah
yeah um
yeah i mean maybe even before then i
hung out with you and joe too
i don't know if we were together just
yet oh you came over to smoke hookah
yeah yeah yeah i forgot what it was for
we were just hanging out and i think
like oh it was just us i know what
happened because i and so i thought my
ex-boyfriend was cheating on me
um and i hit you up about it cause like
you're like yeah i have some stuff i
want to say or some [ __ ] yeah um and i
came over and you were supposed to
reveal something which wasn't anything
at all and i was remembering i remember
i was in your bed and i was just like so
sad because i was crying
um
because i thought he was like talking
other chicks and and i think there was i
think he was actually talking to a
foreign exchange chick not that i knew
of cause he had to he is already in the
korean crowd yeah so i was like
and i remember thinking like why the
[ __ ] did bart waste my time when he
didn't have anything to tell me but he
made me come over and i was in your bed
i mean you were nowhere in the bed like
you were across and i was like just
crying and [ __ ] and then your stupid ass
the next day was like hey um my bed
smells like or my sheets smell like
guacamole
and i think that's also why we kept
talking about anyway so it's revealed
that we're both like in likes with each
other
it was really good that's why i didn't
forget it and then um i'm back home and
i'm like okay wait what is this what are
we doing i'm like can you please come
over like we gotta we gotta sort this
[ __ ] out yeah and then you came over and
like i think the first thing i did when
i opened the doors i just hugged you
yeah i remember
felt good i hugged you so hard um would
you help me so hard because i liked you
so much i couldn't stop thinking about
you and like
i had never felt this way before like it
was just this instant like
perfect piece
that like just
molded into me that like just needed to
be there it was just so perfect i never
hugged anyone on my tippy toes before
too
[ __ ] i saw the girls you dated you
dated nothing but taller chicks that's
true there were some chicks that are
talking all of the chicks were tall
there was like that foreign exchange
chick uh from like bolivia or i don't
know where the [ __ ] [ __ ]
kazakhstan who knows where the [ __ ] she
was from russia i don't know
um anyway yeah i saw all those chicks uh
yeah and then and then
yeah i think like we had that
conversation and
and then i think since then it like
everything felt like it moved too slow
but in reality was really [ __ ] fast
yeah like within that month you had like
already moved in we told each other we
loved each other well even before that
the reason why i think i felt slow too
is um
i feel like i like to live life by a
code
you know and at that time in your early
20s like
the bros are everything yeah right and
so i was like oh man dating yeah we
hadn't done anything yeah i was like i
didn't kiss we hadn't had sex yeah i was
like dating a homie's ex i was like man
to me at that time that's a big no-no
you know
so like
i also man if this happens i need to get
the homies blessing even though me and
him don't really talk anymore you know
and i was like i got to do things right
because that's that's not how
i want to live but i also don't want to
like have a premature scare
you know like the last thing that the
worst the the worst nightmare is like yo
man hey what's up melanie we don't even
work out and you are talking right yeah
and then [ __ ] two weeks later oh
she's a [ __ ]
and then put something on the line
that's like it's irreversible you know
so i think for me like my internal clock
and i think i probably mentioned to you
i was like
um
we can talk
that's it but it's but after 30 days i
need to talk to you because i remember
for some reason that 30 days was so
important in my brain i'm like after 30
days i need to let them know i need to
yeah we didn't i didn't know that 30
days oh but i guess it was in my mind
because i wanted to make sure it's not
like a two-week fling just talking it's
cool now you know it's like
you're on the rebound or i'm on a
rebound or it's just convenient or it's
like christmas spirit i don't know what
the hell's going on you know yeah it was
weird i just i just know
everything has its honeymoon face and i
didn't want it to be that if it's going
to be that big of news
so we were just talking and then i think
um it was like okay cool i was like i
think 30 days were up or something
and at that time was probably like
mid-november now
and that's when i was like
i don't know if you remember but i told
you hey i scheduled to meet up with him
yeah of course yeah i was part of that
whole decision yeah i was like i'm gonna
go meet up with him
and then um i met i went to go met up
with him at a golf course he's like
[ __ ] playing golf for now yeah that
was so weird [ __ ] is this dude yeah it's
so weird this is the same maybe that was
him the whole time this is the same dude
right outside of college
me and him because we we set up a um
a fight club
after school that there would be
fighters
yes there were fights every thursday and
friday after school
and me and him were like [ __ ] a lot
of people up so we thought we were good
fighters and we would go to all the
local martial arts schools muay thai
whatever and challenge schools and like
if you guys if you got a guy like a
whoop our ass
we'll join
that's the guy who we were who we were
and now he's [ __ ] worried and this
one's not [ __ ] wearing playing golf
i'm like who the [ __ ] are you but
anyways i met with them at the golf
course and i'm like yo i know we haven't
talked in a while um
but there's something important i want
to bring up
and i want uh your blessing and he was
like
and he's like all right what is it
and then i'm like uh me and jio are
talking
and i'm and i think it's pretty serious
and i think we like each other
and he was like whoa he starts laughing
ah well that's crazy like what you guys
oh my god you know he just like has that
whole like laugh type of thing and i'm
like no it's i think it's really serious
man i'm like
you guys would never work and i'm like
he's like watch invite me to your
wedding yeah and i was like uh if it
does you guys are too similar or some
[ __ ] i don't know what he said but i
forgot but i just remember him like
scoffing it off
and i think because he was on that like
yeah right it's gonna work too he goes
yeah you have my blessing i'm like
do i really have it or you're being
sarcastic well go ahead do whatever you
want to do
and he was
already like mr korean golfer boy so i
think it was like really going that way
and then we thought we would always go
to the same college we're going to the
rival school it's like a movie um he
goes to sc i go to ucla and then um
yeah and i remember coming back and
telling you
so i talked to him
not
too sure how it went but he did verbally
say he gave the blessing and we [ __ ]
so hard that night i'm just kidding yeah
and then i was like i was like we did
because i don't remember
no no we did it and then yeah and then
uh
that was
that was the start of it
of us like really
committing ourselves to it
and then i remember the night of
christmas is when we got together
yeah that was the night where i was like
we were just laying in bed just talking
not doing anything and um and i was like
hey bart even that felt so good i know
and then you were like yeah
i'm like never mind
and then you were like
something like yeah i feel the same way
too or something i just said me too yeah
like never mind i'm like
me too
and you're like what no something like i
was about to say like um you're about to
say i love you yeah and then like like
your answer fit
like as if i had already just said it
and that's why i said me too yeah and i
was like wait you two what
and then like you like you basically
shared that like
you knew i was gonna say i love you
because you like loved me too and i was
like
what the [ __ ] is going on and it was
that was it that was it like i just you
were my person like that was
yeah that was just the end of it yeah
and then here we are 13 years later
that's crazy
we didn't work out huh just kidding it's
going to be 14 this year yeah
13 years
and a little hairless monkey later i
know and it's [ __ ] cuny yeah that's
crazy big tubby you big dummy i [ __ ]
love you you promise
are you sure you love me
are you sure you love me and on that
note everybody prove it prove it that
you love me what the [ __ ] you know i
love you shut up no i don't think so um
yeah i mean
it was it's such a cool story oh i feel
like all cuny and [ __ ]
it's such a cuny story and i love it
it's very case um how far we've come you
know yeah
so far it comes so far
like we've gone through so many ups and
downs in a relationship and i feel like
um like when i hear people say like oh
relationship goals or whatever
i'm like thank you you know it's
flattering but like with any
relationship it takes a lot of work a
lot
even not romantic you know like you're
gonna have a good father-son
yeah or father daughter mother daughter
or even all relationships if you want it
to be good like right now i'm actively
working on um my relationship with my
mom and my dad
because i know they want to be even
closer i'm like so it's got to be i
gotta do what it takes you know like
every relationship yeah and i love where
we're at right now you know like um
it just feels really good it feels
really not comfortable but it just feels
like very connected it feels like we
have the same goals of mine it feels
like um
we're partners and [ __ ]
um and it feels like like we don't have
big obstacles that like we're against
each other you know it feels like
there's obstacles ahead that we see that
we're like are we ready and then we just
kind of like we suit up and we arm we're
up and we're side by side yeah
and it's really cuny very cuny um
because we had that in the beginning
and then somehow we kind of lost
ourselves a little bit and then we were
able to to come back to this space but
like i think was just like the work
relationship balance like yeah we
um were unprepared for that we were
young it takes a lot of maturity to know
like
um
like you know how to balance the two or
even what balance means right you know
you can't give a kid candy
because this full you can't let them set
their own diet yeah because they're
gonna they're gonna eat nothing but
candy they're gonna crush candy because
they don't understand balance right yeah
and it's like you keep growing and you
don't really know what balance is
so we just go okay cool time to work
work work work work work work this is
what we're supposed to do it's early
twenty it's a ton of work yeah and then
we're like oh [ __ ] the relationship fell
by the wayside well we didn't think we
needed to nurture it yeah we just
thought that it was just something else
and our parents are our role models and
they don't talk about [ __ ] yeah there
are workhorses and you just go okay if
they worked out then this is the way
until you the relations start feeling
falling apart and you start looking at
each other as co-workers rather than
significant others yeah and like oh man
we got a really really big void here
what's going on yeah yeah but no no it
feels like
we're a team you know and like i feel
i feel like when we both have [ __ ] on
our minds like we're usually the first
people to tell each other even if it's
not sorted out whereas before it felt
like things needed to be sorted out
before they could be like polished and
presented you know yeah but i love you i
love doing life with you i love you too
you're my best friend you big cuny guy
well this was cool going back down
memory lane and [ __ ] yeah we hadn't done
that in [ __ ] forever since the last
video or the first and last video
um on jk yeah no on my our personal
channel
you did your story i did my story that's
so cute yeah um that's it that's all i
got
what about you
so i got two bikini all right well let's
go have sex now okay let's do it
all right thank you guys so much for
watching i hope we
um
we were able to uh i don't know help you
guys out if you guys are going through
any type of relationship stuff or just
um i don't know took you guys down
memory lane as well so thank you so much
and we'll see you guys next week or if
there's also um
any part of the story that you guys are
like oh man i'd love to like know deeper
about that yeah we're open book yeah
like let's let's make it uh let's make
it game of thrones you know like we dive
into
a specific episode or a specific
storyline
because that's the main like love story
but i mean
during that time there's like there's a
ton so many things going on there's a
ton when me and joe are packing
for stuff you know what does it feel
like to work a corporate gig
you know like oh like right out of
and then what does it feel like for you
to give up your corporate gig to work on
jk stuff
so much yeah but thank you so much and
uh yeah let us know if there's anything
you guys want us to dive into and we'll
see you guys next week bye